the GOP is hitting back hard as
President Biden tries to blame the ultra
Maga crowd for his endless economic
problems Scranton Joe rolling up his
sleeves to shovel his nonsense talking
points on inflation the president out in
farm country today pushing the same
tired talking points blaming Putin and
those greedy corporations Biden refusing
to take responsibility as we learn the
surge in prices is stuck at a 40-year
high GOP lawmakers calling out the
president for his inaction
Joe Biden will blame anyone but himself
for this inflation I mean he's blamed
chicken farmers and the coronavirus and
Vladimir Putin and everything else Under
the Sun President Biden is flailing
around swinging blindly hoping that
something will land the truth is that
the bad Administration just keeps
kicking its own ass after 14 months
nothing is built
nothing is back and nothing is better he
was supposed to give his ideas on
inflation yesterday what were his ideas
oh it's everybody else's fault but his
as Biden gets blamed for record
inflation he is finding one group
willing to defend his atrocious record
on the economy guess who
a Democrats in office the deficit goes
down the economy flourishes and then a
republican comes in and destroys it all
well and then the next Democrats to come
in and whip it up you defend the former
guy because I won't but I will say until
the pandemic the economy was soaring we
had a record economics because we had
President Barack Obama
Biden is the guy who said listen we need
to give people more money he's in a room
with loose boards he takes a step over
here he gets hit by the ward he takes a
step over here he gets hit by gas going
up and it's not on him and where's Joe
Biden's task force on this parents
growing increasingly desperate over a
national shortage a baby formula 40
percent of America's supplies are out of
stock
okay Jesse I'll start with you do you
think that people who are sitting at
their kitchen table trying to pay their
bills already paying 5 000 more than
they did than last year to maintain the
same standard of living give a damn
about who's to blame as opposed to what
Joe Biden is going to do about I'm just
trying to figure out what they said on
the view
it was over my head really really
enlightening
um apparently if you listen to The View
if you're sitting around the kitchen
table everything's terrible but none of
it's Joe Biden's fault Joe Biden came in
he was supposed to care more and he was
supposed to be more competent and it's
clear now he's neither right now he went
to a farm
and I know he's not running for
re-election because you know where the
farm was farmers in Illinois
if you're running for your election you
go to a farm in Iowa and this guy's done
he's not going anywhere and he wasn't
even in front of like some nice corn
stalks or anything like that you got to
go out if you're going to a farm you got
to see a farm you got to see green you
got to see stocks I couldn't see any of
it here's the other thing he goes out
there and he says that the farmers are
going to get technical assistance from
the government
you think Farmers need help from the
government
the formers they don't need help they
know how to plant crops what's the
government going to tell the farmers to
do and by the way it's a little too late
for that help they plant crops based on
Seasons they have systems we knew when
Ukraine was invaded what two and a half
months ago this was the biggest
fertilizer exporter this is the biggest
energy producer Russia two and a half
months later Joe now says we're going to
do something about fertilizer food and
energy where has this guy been I don't
know where he's been I know this
all of a sudden he says big business is
like getting in the middle and jacking
up prices because they're greedy well
they could have been doing that the last
40 years why after 40 years they decide
now they're going to get greedy it
doesn't even make any sense yeah well
you know what I think that uh Joe Biden
thought he was in Iowa when he was in
Illinois but you know what I'll go to
you Martha because he did I mean Jesse's
right Joe Biden came in as the empathic
sympathetic guy I mean that actually got
him into office he cared about covet
where is the mercy now that Americans
need who can't pay their bills
so you know I go back to the view and
trying to break down what they were
saying there and I look at what Alyssa
Ferris said and the truth is that the
biggest stimulus that we've had to the
economy in the last several years was at
the beginning of the Trump
Administration when you had the cutting
of regulations and the uh cutting the
depreciation all of those taxes that
businesses that are the biggest part of
what businesses pay as soon as that
happened you saw businesses expanding
um buying more companies employing more
people cutting through the red tape and
regulation was probably the most
effective stimulus to the economy that
we've seen in a long time these are not
words that you're hearing across This
president's lips that is the thing that
would generate real growth in this
country when you have inflation and
everyone's costs are going up and you've
got supply chain issues and costs are
going up the best thing that you can do
is to cut taxes give people relief give
them incentives in order to stimulate
their businesses and that is the most
direct way to do it Whoopi Goldberg says
um you know that he's putting money back
in people's pockets well we hear these
efforts oh we're going to lower
prescription drug price is we're going
to make Child Care cheaper and that will
offset inflation but that is such a
roundabout way to try to get at it the
most immediate thing you can do is to
cut taxes cut regulation make it easier
for people to open their businesses to
make those businesses bigger we're not
hearing any of those really direct
things that would actually impact
inflation in the economy fairly quickly
Geraldo I mean you've got to have some
thoughts on this I mean the he the blame
game doesn't work for people who are
trying to survive well I think Rick's
got calling the president incapacitated
and incoherent is playing the the blame
game judge I I think he's coherent I I
think that he has in part been very
unlucky there is no doubt but that the
pandemic and the Ukraine war have had an
impact and there's also no doubt that
the president himself with his
generosity pouring billions of dollars
into the economy has helped fuel the
inflation rate uh and uh and help cause
gum up up the supply chain but now when
I hear about him talking about lowering
taxes to help people out that's the last
thing I think the economy needs is more
money dumped in if inflation is the
issue now I support a lot of people you
know I'm blessed that I that I can I've
never heard them complain more about
being on fixed incomes and it's very
very discussing the rent went from uh
you know at the 5 000 to say whatever it
is I don't know but uh it is very
distressing and I think that uh the the
difficulty is being disciplined enough
to find the way out you've got to cut
off the Beast you've got to stop
shoveling public money into the trough
and expecting uh you know that's not
going to burn okay well Brian I mean
that is the answer I mean even the Wall
Street Journal is suggesting that Joe
Biden AKA president Costanza from
Seinfeld do the opposite of what he's
done right and we rolled that clip this
morning on Seinfeld I know you don't put
the sound up when Foxon
you know everybody has natural when you
take over yet natural disasters you have
wars you have challenges I get it but
when he took over you can't blame the
pandemic he had a vaccine he was ready
to go he was going to fix things then he
had 800 billion from Trump and then he
chose to spend a print to 1.9 trillion
more and then the Ukrainian situation he
told us this was going to happen ahead
of time if he got those weapons in
quicker this thing could be over already
so he's made decisions that made
everything a lot worse and I think we've
said a lot already but we didn't bring
up Ultra Maga that to me is the problem
Ultra Maga he's getting he's going to
Madison Avenue trying to get a uh trying
to get a buzzword to blame somebody he
goes into Rick Scott's 11 point plan and
finds one line unlined a number five
that says I think everybody the 50 that
don't pay income taxes should pay income
taxes and he wasted all that time
labeling the Trump people and then then
going to Rick Scott's plan from
Wisconsin I was following Rick Scott in
Florida I don't know what I was thinking
because he was the following yeah
your arch enemies in the wrong State
yeah so by the way he's not Ultra Maga
Rick's got just a typical Conservative
Republican he's not Matt Gates so he has
the wrong he had everything messed up
and I I resent the fact that he wasted
so much time and energy with his staff
to try to blame people instead of fixing
it you're 79 years old stop trying to
win the next election just do your job
yeah well apparently he doesn't quite
know how to fix it that could be it
anyway coming up the left is flipping
out over Elon musk's plan to lift the
Twitter ban on Trump I wonder Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now